hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to secure a
peripheral iv
before performing any nursing skills you
want to make sure that you're following
your hospital's protocols
to ensure you're following the latest
guidelines
once you have inserted the iv aspirated
for blood return flush
and clamped it off per your facilities
protocol you'll want to secure the iv
in place i'm going to with this
particular dressing you want to get
familiar with your kits because
everything's different
i'm going to take this part
off like so and i'm going to hold it at
this end
and has a notched area so i want this
part to lay
on the top of the cap where before it
goes in
to the access the extension set so i'm
just going to
lay it there i'm going to apply some
firm pressure just to
get it down on the skin
okay so i'm securing that down
by touching it then what i want to do is
i want to slightly compress these sides
and i'm going to just lift this tubing
up just a little bit
because i want those notch parts to get
underneath that
part of the ivy
so i'm pressing everything down making
sure it's nice and secure
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to tear off these edges around
the eye be this part right here
little edges
and then as you're doing that just push
it down make sure it sticks to the skin
because you don't want to lose your ivy
after you have started it
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take this part
of the tape this big piece
and i'm going to lay it across
this part so it just provides
extra securement so we have that there
i'm applying pressure
like that i'm just sealing it down
nice and sealed then with this
particular extension tubing
remember the letter j okay because
that's how you want to
secure it down we don't want this
flopping everywhere that's going to put
tension
on the iv line causing possibly the iv
to slip out
and we want to protect it and then
there's this other piece of tape that
you will use
to secure the tail of the iv
so i've already went ahead and filled it
out i've put the insertion date here
put whatever date your facility requires
you to put so i'm going to peel
that off and i'm going to put this up
again in the
j shape and i'm going to lay that
there and i'm going to just take this
piece of tape
and just slide it on this part
and then be sure you smooth the edges
down
so that it sticks and that will just
help protect that site from
falling out and just keep it more secure
then dispose of this
in the receptacle area that your
facility requires you to dispose these
types of things in
remove our gloves perform hand hygiene
and document
okay so that wraps up this video and if
you'd like to watch more videos on
nursing skills you can access the link
in the youtube description below